ich sage ganz offen meine Meinung und
ich gebe Ihnen recht wenn sie sagen es
ist manchmal hart
aber ganz ehrlich da muss ich Ihnen auch
sagen das halte ich aus entspannt und es
steht nie immer zu meiner Tür und sagten
ich halte es auch aus aber es gibt
Menschen die natürlich schon deswegen
ist nicht aushalten können weil sie
sozial sich nicht leisten können ihren
Job zu verlieren weil sie einfach noch
relativ jung sind und irgendwie eine
Perspektive haben müssen und da ist das
eine ziemlich harte Geschichte ich kenne
Mails Lehrerinnen und Lehrer die mir
schreiben wenn sie dann bestimmte Dinge
kritisieren dass sie dann auch deutlich
unter Druck geraten dass sie sich das
überlegen wo sie noch öffentlichere
Meinung sagen das findet doch statt und
das ist ein großes Problem in unserer
Debatte und wie gesagt ich ich meine ich
mir mich Fisch das nicht an aber es ist
natürlich auch nicht schön wenn man
öffentlich weil man für eine
Friedenslösung wird dann eben als
putinfreundin hingestellt wird oder als
irgendwie Russland
ja oder was auch immer also das ist
einfach eine Unkultur und bei anderen
Themen ist es auch so weil das
heizungsgesetz passiert da wurde dann
auch ganz schnell geraunt ob man nicht
den Klimaschutz wichtig findet also ja
natürlich gibt es kritisiert worden ist
in den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten
als das heizungsgesetz noch nur ganz
kurz nochmal der Staat was der Staat uns
alles vorschreibt ja also reden und
denken haben wir jetzt gerade nicht so
richtig hingekriegt essen was ist mit
Essen wer schreibt den vor was sie zu
essen haben mir schreibt niemand vor was
ich zu essen habe wir haben aber sie
sagen ein übergriffiger Staat der uns
vorschreibt was sie zu essen haben es
ist doch eine Debatte die dahin läuft
nicht so meinen warum warum wenn jemand
sein Schnitzel bei Aldi kauft dann wird
der öffentlich als jemand hingestellt
dem das Tierwohl egal ist der ignorant
ist gegenüber dem Klimaschutz der
einfach sich über alles hinwegsetzt
dabei sind das überwiegend Leute die
können sich kein Bioladen leisten und
die wollen eben auch gerne Schnitzel
essen also wir haben doch diese arrogant
in der Diskussion natürlich ist es
niemanden verboten sein Schnitzel bei
Aldi zu kaufen aber wenn dafür
herabgesetzt wird wenn er dafür
moralisch herangehen würde und das sind
die Debatten die wir in Deutschland
haben bin ich total weint wenn ich total
weinen aber sie sind ich meine
Germanistin sie sind so präzise in der
Semantik der Staat was hat der Staat
damit natürlich regierende Position
an den staatlichen Aufseher gesehen der
in schlechtes Gewissen gemacht hat bei
den Schnitzel rausgeholt haben nein aber
Regierungspolitiker die Statements
abgeben die Leute die so etwas kaufen in
die Ecke stellen ich erlebe wie ein
bestimmte Lebensart geächtet wird wie
sie herabgewürdigt wird
gerade im letzten Jahr haben wir doch
ständig Belehrung bekommen wir brauchen
nur ein Raumtemperatur von 19 Grad und
dann stellen sich Politiker hin und
erklären den Leuten wie Sie Ihre Heizung
runter drehen sollen und man auch denkt
für wie ernst nehmen die eigentlich ihre
Wählerschaft also das ist doch eine
Attitüde die wir immer stärker haben und
natürlich natürlich auch eine immer
stärkere Druckausübung die ja indirekt
damit verbunden ist weil natürlich ist
moralischer rapssetzung ist etwas was
dazu führt dass Menschen sich mit ihrer
Lebensweise nicht mehr nach außen trauen
oder auch sich in eine Ecke gestellt
sehen und ich meine der Effekt ist
natürlich dass am Ende viele deswegen
auch AFD wählen weil die dann solche
Dinge aufgreifen
also ich meine kennen Sie diese
Diskussion nicht
öffentlich diskutieren das ist doch dass
die Leute so nicht leben sondern man
soll auch nicht mehr Verbrennerauto
rumfahren mit einem E-Auto fahren sich
aber die meisten Leute auch nicht
leisten ist es nicht genau das Wesen die
Idee von Demokratie das ist dann Leute
wie sie gibt die das jeden zweiten Abend
öffentlich vor Millionen von Menschen
Geißeln und sie dürfen das
ja aber es ist doch trotzdem zum
Beispiel wenn Dinge verteuert werden ja
ich sag ja auch nicht dass wir der DDR
Leben ich bin heilfroh dass wir nicht
mehr in der DDR leben das ist da worauf
ich hinaus will ja aber man muss doch
genau gucken wo bei uns Dinge wieder
beginnen die tatsächlich auch bedrohlich
sind und ich meine der corona-politik
war es extrem in der corona-zeit wurde
ein wirklich vorgeschrieben wann man
noch sein Haus verlassen dürfte was man
sich impfen lassen durfte da war es ganz
extrem das haben sie ja teilweise sogar
auch kritisiert also habe ich aber sehen
Sie auch da wieder sie haben sich
entschlossen sich nicht impfen zu lassen
und niemand konnte ihn dafür irgendetwas
ja irgendetwas ich durfte in halbes Jahr
in kein Restaurant und kein Kaffee ich
durfte nicht einkaufen gehen außerhalb
der Supermärkte sowie alle anderen die
sich nicht am impfen lassen also man war
gesellschaftlich völlig raus aus dem
öffentlichen Leben und ich sag mal das
ist jetzt im Alter von Boba 50
vielleicht noch okay aber bei jungen
Menschen die mit ihrer Truppe mit ihren
Freunden aus machen sie sich nicht so
alt nein aber ich sag mal es ist
natürlich schon oder wo man nicht mehr
irgendwie ins Sportstudio und das müsste
man auch nicht mehr man hatte man konnte
wenn man in einem Club war Fußballclub
alles nicht mehr also das war natürlich
das war der drastischste eigentlich
war heftig und ich möchte nicht dass ich
das noch mal wiederholt also ich meine
wir haben das nie aufgearbeitet bis
heute nicht man was anderes wenn man das
nicht möchte oder viele Leute deswegen
die FDP gewählt weil sie das nicht mehr
wollten dann kriegten sie die Ampel und
dann kam zwei bundesweit also lass uns
nicht über Corona sprechen auf jeden
Fall haben sie nicht DIE LINKE gewählt
ja weil sie offenbar auch nicht mit
entsprechenden Positionen auffällig
geworden ist also darum sind sie
eigentlich noch in Berlin
weil ich mich immer noch viel
Mitgliedern verbunden fühle aber vor
allem auch weil ich finde wenn man etwas
kaputt macht dann sollte man das nur
machen wenn man schon weiß dass man
etwas Neues aufbauen kann sonst hat man
einfach auch eine Verantwortung
also ich rede über die Fraktion der
Bundes
[Gelächter]
kaputt macht gut sehr schön Frau
wie hören Sie dazu gerade interessieren
ist für die Recherche für mein Buch über
die Zukunft habe ich auch eine ganz
interessante
Statistik der Bertelsmann Stiftung
gefunden wo ähm Wahlverhalten korreliert
wurde mit Angst vor der Zukunft das wird
jetzt natürlich nicht überraschen das
klingt ja auch so durch aus dem was sie
so sagen dass Mila der Linken aber auch
der AFD überproportional oder mehr Angst
vor der Zukunft haben als jetzt Wähler
der Grünen und der FDP z.B das sieht man
ja auch an ihren politischen Positionen
also eigentlich was sie wollen ist das
alles so bleibt wie es ist und es kann
ich auch
ziemlich der härteste Vorwurf der immer
machen kann sie wollen nicht das den
Krieg in dem Krainer das natürlich nicht
aber sie wollen weiterhin dass das dass
das Schnitzel okay ist dass das normale
Auto okay ist dass keine Migranten
kommen dass es keine keine gender Fluid
identity gibt alles in Ordnung aber Fakt
ist die Welt verändert sich und ein Teil
der Gesellschaft ist schon dabei und sie
sind halt im hinteren hinteren Welle
quasi und das tut ihm weh und das
verstehe ich auch aber die Welt
verändert sich und ich glaube dass sie
und die Leute die sich bei Ihnen wohl
fühlen dass im Grunde genommen eine ganz
Gruppe ganz große Gruppe Zukunft Angst
ist das kann ich nachvollziehen aber der
Zukunft heißt nicht sich vor ihr
wegdrücken denn die kommt sowieso ja
aber es gibt doch nicht die Zukunft es
gibt verschiedene zukunftsmöglichkeit
aber sie wünschen sich doch dass die
Zukunft genauso ist wie sie gerade
beschrieben haben Schnitzel bei Aldi
kein Auto keine Ahnung
95 also eigentlich wünsche ich mir
sowieso 1995 ewig 1995
zurechtigkeit wenn die Ampel so
weitermacht oder wenn die nächste
Regierung die Politik der Ampel
fortsetzt dann habe ich große Angst vor
der Zukunft unseres Landes weil ich sehe
dass unsere Industrie kaputt geht
richtig
ich will jetzt nicht ich bin ich bin
nicht Parteien dieser grünen aber selbst
wenn einem die grüne Politik weh tut
fakt ist dahinter ist der Klimawandel
und da können wir jetzt noch die
nächsten fünf Jahre so weitermachen als
wäre nicht wir merken es ja jetzt schon
es wird immer heißer wir können diesen
Lebensstil nicht weiter folgen so in der
Umsetzung ist das vielleicht viele Orts
falsch und ganz sicherlich ist es
arrogant für viele gebe ich Ihnen Recht
aber Fakt ist dass wir müssen uns dem
stellen und einfach sagen ich möchte
aber weniger arrogant behandelt werden
dafür dass ich mich nicht verändern will
das geht nicht wir müssen uns alle
verändern
welche Veränderungen sind voll ist also
das was wir zurzeit machen das was habe
ich zurzeit macht ein Politik das
bekämpft den Klimawandel überhaupt nicht
im Gegenteil also der der Beitrag zum
Beispiel dieses heizungsgesetz aber
betreibt es auch nicht gut ist ja wohl
eher die Frage wie die Schweine vorher
gehalten wurden als ob man das Schnitzel
ist so und da ist ja auch ein völliger
Widerspruch also zum Beispiel wenn wir
über Massentierhaltung reden also diese
Regierung verhandelt über
Freihandelsabkommen mit dem Markus Suhr
das bringt ganz billiges Fleisch nach
Deutschland dann werden die
Massentierhaltung bei uns wahrscheinlich
aus Südamerika
und ich meine natürlich kann sein dann
gehen hier die Bauern alle Pleite also
haben wir hier keine Massentierhaltung
mehr wir sind ganz edel aber wir führen
das dann von woanders ein und so ist es
ja in vielen Bereichen wenn wir die
Industrie hier in Deutschland vertreiben
weil wir mit äh mit mit missionshandel
und Tonen Energiepreisen ihnen das Leben
schwer machen heißt das doch nicht dass
das Weg klimap profitiert sondern dann
wird woanders produziert oft wesentlich
dreckiger produziert und das ist doch
was sich der Regierung vorwerfe es ist
doch gar keine es ist ja gar keine
irgendwie durchdachte Plan volle Politik
weder in Richtung auf Klima Belange noch
in Richtung auf soziale so lange es ist
einfach kurzsichtig es ist dilettantisch
es ist teilweise auch inkompetent wenn
das heizungsgesetz zum Beispiel hat
jetzt ja sogar die wärmepumpenbranche
ausgebremst also die brechen gerade ein
weil das alles so völlig falsch gemacht
wurde aber es ist auch da wir brauchen
ja ein langfristiges Konzept wo kommt
der Strom her also wenn immer mehr zum
Beispiel auf E-Auto und Wärmepumpe
gesetzt wird die brauchen Strom dafür
hat aber die Regierung kein Konzept also
ist das doch keine Klimapolitik wenn
nachher ganz viele Wärmepumpen mit
Kohlestrom betrieben werden also dann
habe ich lieber eine Gasheizung also das
ist einfach nicht logisch das ist doch
gleich mal ganz konkret inhaltlich
sprechen machen wir sofort wieder gerne
von Herrn Lehmann der die ganze Zeit
weil er höflicher Mensch ist sich
zurückhält aber der schon rutscht auf
seinem Stuhl hin und her und auf und ab
und so ähnlich mal das Kind ihn durch
den Kopf wenn sie das Hören also was
passiert da gerade auch politisch das
ist ja schon interessant ne das jetzt
sozusagen ein weiteres Mal eine ganze
Flanke sozusagen aufbricht und die Frage
ist gibt es so wie Frau Wagenknecht das
beschreibt und das lese auch immer
wieder ein Umfrage
dass Leute sagen na ja da gibt es
offenbar Potenzial für eine weitere eine
neue politische Kraft woher kommt das
ich würde sagen also was wir sehen auf
jeden Fall in Umfragen dass der Wagen
nicht parteienpotenzial von 20 Prozent
nachgesagt wird Potenzial heißt aber
erstmal noch nicht viel also die SPD hat
über Potenzial von 45 Prozent oder so
die wählen aber sind Leute gerufen
meinen sie so sieht's aus also die Frage
ist was kann eigentlich eine Waage was
könnte eine Wagen nicht Partei von
diesen 20% am Ende wirklich holen und
natürlich ist es so ich meine das hört
man jetzt gerade bei allen Themen die
Frau Wagen nicht jetzt hier in den
letzten Minuten angesprochen hat sind
das alles vielfach die Themen die die
AFD auch anspielt ich würde das in
keinster Weise gleichsetzen ja der
Thüringer AFD vom Verfassungsschutz der
Thüringer Landesverband wird als
gesichert rechtsextreme eingestuft das
ist bei Frau Wagenknecht da ist Frau
Wagen nicht weit von entfernt man muss
auch sagen weil die Frage ist wer ist
eigentlich dabei weil sie ein paar mal
davon eingespielt haben das muss man
sich glaube ich auch klar machen was
wäre diese Wagen nicht Partei das ist
ein Teil der Link Datei der Wagenknecht
Flügel Klaus Ernst der ist Klaus Ernst
beispielsweise dabei der frühere
Vorsitzende der Linken da ist eine Sevim
dadelin dabei eine außenpolitikerin der
sind viele Hinterbänkler die man in der
Öffentlichkeit nicht so kennt aber das
ist nicht nur Wagen nicht alleine sie
ist natürlich die entscheidende Figur
für diese Partei aber es ist ein Flügel
von etwa ein Viertel der Linkspartei der
sich dort in diese neue Partei
eingliedern würde und das ist die werden
dann weg dort die werden dann nicht mehr
da die würden dann austreten in Teilen
sind sie schon ausgetreten Frau war
nichts Ehemann er Lafontaine hat ja
bereits seinen Austritt erklärt da war
noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen dabei
die ihren Austritt erklärt haben die
warten teilweise jetzt sehensüchtig
darauf dass Frau Wagen nicht jetzt
endlich mal sagt das Sache ist ob sie
jetzt diese Partei gründet oder nicht
heute schon gesagt ja sie wartet nur auf
den richtigen Moment es ist klar ich
warte darauf dass die Voraussetzung
es ist klar dass Frau Wagenknecht und
ihre mitstreitet
die Frage kriegen sie es organisatorisch
hin und da sind sie immer noch am
ausprobieren da gibt es einfach viele
Fragen die ungeklärt sind und das wird
man sehen ob sie das hinkriegen also
sicherlich ist es schwer eine eigene
Partei aus dem mich zu gründen und mit
Aufstehen das war übrigens die gleiche
Gruppe das war auch das Lager um Frau
Wagen nicht die das versucht haben damit
sind sie gescheitert und das wird man
jetzt wieder versuchen noch ein Punkt
weil gesagt hat Frau Wagenknecht ist
1995 oder will bleiben wie es ist ewig
für immer 95 für immer 1995 das ist der
Buchtitel der heute abend
ich möchte nicht dass es so bleibt ich
möchte den Teil zurück sie zurück in die
Zukunft zurück in die Jahre die 60er
Jahre da sieht sie den Sozialstaat als
in Perfektion dort ist sozusagen der
aufstiegsgedanke für die für die Leute
am besten gewesen diesen Seiten zurück
zum Nationalstaat die EU so abbauen das
ist eigentlich das was Frau Wagenknecht
möchte in Teilen auch Gesellschaft
olitisch
also ich würde sogar noch weitergehen
ich finde wirklich merkwürdig wenn man
darauf verweist dass bestimmte Dinge in
der Vergangenheit besser geregelt waren
dass man dann das einem dann unterstellt
wird zurück also ist doch völlig
selbstverständlich wir haben den
Klimawandel also muss es etwas muss es
natürlich in neue Technologien geben die
Frage ist aber eben ob das was jetzt
gemacht wird eine angebliche
Klimapolitik oder eine wirkliche
Klimapolitik ist für mich ist das Fake
ich meine gerade die Energie
wird sozusagen
und der Geschichte und so weiter wie
würden sie es machen
also ich finde Deutschland Deutschland
ist wichtigste
Beitrag den Deutschland im Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel leisten könnte wäre
endlich wieder Zukunftstechnologien hier
in Deutschland zu entwickeln die dann
auch für die Welt nutzbar sind heißt zum
Beispiel beim Auto statt jetzt auf den
Zug der abgefahren ist der E-Mobilität
sich einfach draufzusetzen hätte man die
Autoindustrie unter Druck setzen müssen
tatsächlich verbrauchsärmere Autos
verbrennerautos mit anderen Brennstoff
zu entwickeln das wäre ein Exportmodell
gewesen ja aber eben nicht diese teuren
die wir jetzt haben weil keiner wirklich
dort forscht oder bzw
was würden Sie dann machen sie geben uns
beispielsweise in der Vergangenheit
falsch gelaufen ist aber wenn sie jetzt
heute handeln müssen was würden Sie
machen also ich würde gucken dass ich
zum Beispiel Öl und Gas wieder mit
Pipelines bekommen und nicht auf dem
Schiffsweg der besonders klimaschädlich
ist sie würden trotzdem 1 und 2 wieder
reparieren ja also bei Öl zum Beispiel
gibt es eine Pipeline die geht nach
Schwedt die haben wir stillgelegt jetzt
holen wir das Öl das russische Öl
wohlgemerkt über Indien auf dem
schiffswegsöl muss man sagen halt
heimlich dahinverkauft das ist viel viel
mehr an Ausstoß so bei Gas ist es
genauso wir kaufen ja immer noch
russisches Gas nur wir kaufen jetzt über
Belgien Flüssiggas das also in Russland
verflüssigt wird dann geht es nach
Belgien da wird es wieder gassifiziert
und wir importieren jetzt Gas aus
Belgien ist natürlich kein russisches
Gas weil es hat ja ein riesen Bogen
gemacht ist sehr sehr klimaschädlich
natürlich dadurch dass es ja eben nicht
durch die Pipeline geht ja natürlich
erstmal wieder die Pipelines Reaktion
zwei würden sie reparieren und dann
wieder ganz normal Gas liefern also
zumindest sollte man das versuchen also
ich meine da gehören ja zwei dazu und
dann müsste man Gespräche führen aber es
ist wenn sie mich haben Umwelt Aspekt
Ion der sinnvollere bewegt
ne zur Erinnerung na ja dann sind sie in
die Luft geflogen und da gibt's ja jetzt
anhalten
Putin hat erstmal zugemacht und dann
sind naja und dort sind zwei haben wir
zugemacht also wir haben gesagt 192
wollen wir nicht und noch eins kam kein
Gas mehr und dann flog es in die Luft so
und jetzt haben wir eben dass die Lämmer
dass wir teures Gas kaufen das auch aus
Russland kommt das genauso den
russischen Staatshaushalt saniert aber
eben sehr viel klimaschädlicher ist so
das ist ein Russland würde ich natürlich
versuchen auf anderen Ebenen ich meine
wir reden jetzt immer darüber dass man
das das Benzin also wie gesagt jetzt
noch mal mit CO2 Preisen teurer werden
muss damit die Leute irgendwie lieber
ihr Auto stehen lassen gleichzeitig
haben wir eine katastrophal
ausgestattete Deutsche Bahn die in der
Regel also wo kein Zug pünktlich ist und
die gleichzeitig auch noch ihren
Schienenverkehr immer mehr reduziert das
ist eine sehr einfache Variante
tatsächlich CO2 zu sparen den Menschen
ein guten öffentlichen nah und
Fernverkehr anzubieten und auch den
Schienenverkehr wieder auszubauen Jahre
man muss ja irgendwann mal anfangen
ich mache jetzt erstmal die Investition
wieder klein geschrumpft ich würde sagen
da müsste man investieren
was noch dann finde ich auch ich meine
warum überlassen wir China neue
Technologien zu erforschen wie zum
Beispiel thoriumreaktoren
kugellaufreaktoren das sind Technologien
nachdem ich bin nicht der Experte in dem
Bereich was mir gesagt wurde das sind
nukleare Technologien die allerdings
nicht mit diesem extremen Risiken
verbunden sind wie die klassischen
Atomkraftwerke deswegen wäre das auch
ein Weg für die Zukunft tatsächlich CO2
werden
also ich meine Zukunft wir können den
aktuellen Technologien teilen das war ja
die These und da würde ich zum Beispiel
einen großen Fond auflegen die zehn
Milliarden die die habe ich versenkt hat
bei Intel um also dort eine Ansiedlung
zu finanzieren die hätte ich in eine
vorgegeben der müsste allerdings noch
größer sein
tatsächlich innovative heimische
industrieheimische Unternehmen Start-ups
zu fördern die solche neuen
Energieformen erforschen und teilweise
vielleicht auch marktfähig machen können
also es ist ein Konzept also Intel wäre
in legal
Intel macht Chips die bei heutiger in
der heutigen Situation relativ modern
sind wo aber viele Experten sagen das
sind nicht die Chips der Zukunft und
außerdem sind es Chips die wir in
Deutschland nicht verwenden können also
es sind Computerchips das sind keine die
die Autoindustrie braucht oder die der
Maschinenbau braucht
Deutschland ansiedeln das wäre sinnvoll
damit oder unheimlichste Technologie
also echte Hightech Chips da werden sie
raus würden sie nicht machen nein ich
sag das ist kein das was Intel macht ist
nicht die Zukunft der Chip-Produktion
sagen zumindest Experten sondern es gibt
europäische Unternehmen
die in Dresden sich ansiedeln wollen was
mit denen Hightech ja wer sich ansiedeln
will ist willkommen
trainieren also ich meine wenn Intel in
Deutschland investiert sehr sehr gerne
aber die Frage ist doch wo man Mittel am
sinnvollsten einsetzt und ich finde wir
setzen Mittel falsch ein wir setzen sie
nicht dahin wo sie besonders sinnvoll
sind und deswegen wäre das zum Beispiel
auch ein Weg um eine Sache ich habe
dieser Tage aus ihrem neuen
Parteiprogramm schon ein bisschen was
gelesen bei den Kunden oder nein ich
meine das Programm ihrer neuen Partei
ach so dass sie das kennen von den
Kollegen von Bild von sie nach den drei
wichtigsten Punkten gefragt und sie
sagten Stopp sind vier und da steht
unter dem Stichwort wirtschaftliche
Vernunft ja ja da steht abenteuerliches
das ist also sie wollen das stimmt alles
gar nicht also wir wollen keine
staatlichen Kontrollorgane die
überwachen was Betriebe Fantasie dieser
bild-mensch entfaltet hat der hat mir
das auch in dem Gespräch erzählt dass er
der Meinung ist dass ich irgendwelche
staatlichen Kontrollorgane haben will
und ich habe ihm gesagt wie kommen Sie
darauf was richtig ist ich finde da wo
Märkte nicht trainieren da muss der
Staat in die Preisbildung eingehen das
sehe ich schon ja das findet ja statt
wer entscheidet das ja aber griffige
böse Stadt sagen sie das jetzt bitte
nicht wer macht das also wir haben in
vielen Bereichen regulierte Preise
übrigens das Land in Europa das in den
meisten Bereichen regulierte Preise hat
wissen Sie welches das ist nein das ist
die Schweiz und sie hat offenbar ist
nicht schlecht damit gefahren und wir
haben einfach in Deutschland wir haben
es doch jetzt gesehen bei der
Energiepolitik wir haben einerseits
natürlich weil wir jetzt uns
abgeschnitten haben von billiger Energie
eine hohe Inflation wir haben aber auch
deshalb eine hohe Inflation bei einige
Unternehmen sehr viel Marktmacht haben
also zum Beispiel Lebensmittelketten die
Lebensmittelkonzerne da werden immer so
ein Gewinde gemacht und da gibt es zwei
Wege ein Weg der ist längerfristig aber
auch sinnvoll man muss große Unternehmen
mit zu viel Markt macht entflechten das
haben die Auto lieber rein immer
gefordert Zerschlagung heißt das
die USA diskutieren jetzt zum Beispiel
darüber bei den großen internetkonzernen
also
man kann das auch mit dem höflichen
Begriff der Entflechtung beschreiben
aber ja natürlich also ich meine
entweder will man das merkt wenn ein
Markt funktionieren soll dann braucht es
Wettbewerb und wenn wir in vielen
Märkten keinen wirklichen Wettbewerb
mehr haben dann führt das natürlich dazu
dass auf der einen Seite Menschen sich
Dinge nicht mehr leisten können und auf
der anderen Seite überbordende Gewinne
gemacht werden und das haben wir jetzt
auch also wir haben ja nicht nur
da würden Sie sagen Freunde Weg nein ich
finde es sinnvoller dafür zu sorgen dass
der Markt wieder funktioniert und
deswegen wie gesagt ja ein Flechtung da
muss man keine Gewinne abschöpfen aber
wir haben ja wirklich ich meine das ist
doch eine perverse Situation wir haben
auf der einen Seite viele Menschen die
wirklich nicht mehr wissen wie sie mit
ihrem Einkommen über den Monat kommen
und hart arbeiten und wir haben
Unternehmen die auch kein Land mehr
sehen weil alles teurer geworden
finden Sie da ja natürlich gibt es in
der Chemieindustrie ganz viele es gibt
aber auch viele Bäcker die in Flechten
also die Supermarktketten werden sie da
so an wir haben ungefähr fünf
Lebensmittel großketten die natürlich
eine enorme Macht haben Preise zu setzen
und darunter leiden die Konsumenten auf
der einen Seite und die Landwirtschaft
auf der anderen Seite
würden sie Edeka zerschlagen ja eDEKA
ist ja eben nicht mehr nur Edeka eDEKA
ist ja ein Verbund eingegangen und das
was machen ja entlichten Fragen sehr
schlagen Herr Brüderle hatte mal einen
flechtungsgesetz tatsächlich auf den Weg
gebracht das hat allerdings dann leider
nicht mehr weiter verfolgt
das nicht sie machen das jetzt ja da wo
die Markt macht zu groß ist muss man die
verschiedenen Unternehmen die sich in
den letzten Jahren zusammengeschlossen
haben wieder auseinander
hat das z.B eine Ölindustrie vielfach
viel lange her Facebook wäre es ja auch
so Facebook Instagram interessant ist
das für Sie jetzt die Amerikaner
plötzlich das Vorbild sind das finde ich
interessant
wenn ein wenn ein Land in einer Sache
etwas richtig macht es ist nicht
deswegen ein Vorbild ich finde aber zum
Beispiel auch die Innovationspolitik in
den USA das ist was ich vorhin gesagt
habe diesen Zukunftsform für innovative
Unternehmen genau das haben die USA
gemacht deswegen ist das Silicon Valley
in den USA und nicht in Deutschland und
nicht woanders aber ganz ehrlich sagen
die Chinesen machen es übrigens auf ihre
Art mit einer Stärke und
staatskomponente ganz ähnlich nur wir
machen nichts und wir werden irgendwann
zerrieben zwischen diesen zweimal aber
weißt doch ganz interessant dass sie
sagen gerade Innovation was ganz
entscheidendes bei Innovationen sind
Ausländer Zuwanderung und sie haben mich
ein gutes Thema haben ja auch
offensichtlich ein Problem damit ähm ich
kann mir schon vorstellen was jetzt
kommt sie sagen nee wir wollen so ganz
gezielte Zuwanderer aber Fakt ist dass
man ein Klima schaffen muss wie in den
USA wo es okay ist dass man aus einem
anderen Land kommt eine andere Religion
hat anders aussieht mit seinen besten
Ideen Stichwort Steve Jobs der ein
syrisches Adoptivkind eigentlich war
aber also irgendwie beißt sich da die
Katze in den Schwanz sie wollen jetzt
ein bisschen reinfahren also naja aber
dann erklären
wenn sie gleichzeitig wenn Firmen Angst
haben müssen vor zerschlagen und
gleichzeitig Ausländer eigentlich nicht
willkommen sind oder wir wollen dann nur
die aber die die wir wollen wollen dann
uns nicht weil wir so ein Klimaschaden
also ich komme am Ende komme ich immer
wieder dabei raus sie haben ultimativ
Angst vor der Komplexität sie haben
Angst und ich verstehe das wie gesagt
aber die Antwort kann nicht sein wir
suchen jetzt nach einfachen Lösung
kleben Pflaster drauf und hoffen einfach
so besser ich habe die nicht Angst weil
nicht viele Dinge auch nicht
existenziell betreffen die Menschen
haben Angst und sie haben runter und sie
haben weil für viele Menschen nicht
besser wird sondern schlechter also wir
haben noch eine coole Menschen besser
geht und nicht wo es ihnen schlechter
geht und ich meine wenn sie jetzt
Zuwanderung ansprechen
gestellt haben Zuwanderung heißt
Innovation also nach dialogik müsste
Deutschland jetzt innovativste Land
dieser Welt sein wir haben eine immense
zuveränderung wir haben über eine
Million Menschen jetzt in relativ kurzer
Zeit wieder aufgenommen und das ist eben
etwas das überfordert ein Land ich sage
doch nicht das Zuwanderung oder auch das
Miteinander unterschiedlicher Kulturen
nicht auch eine Bereicherung sein können
aber doch nicht das kommt doch auf die
Größenordnung an das kommt doch darauf
an dass Integration funktioniert dass
die Infrastruktur nicht überfordert wird
das Schulen Wohnungen da sind Lehrer da
sind Kitaplätze da sind das ist aber
alles nicht das gibt USA nicht es gibt
einfach nur eine andere Kultur in den
USA gibt's ja auch also ich würde auch
nicht sagen dass
einfach Sozialstaat Deutschland es
funktioniert nicht also natürlich
die Milch und die Butter haben sagt man
auf Französisch eine innovative
Wirtschaft haben und trotzdem einen
starken Sozialstaat das beißt sich doch
nicht im Gegenteil also wenn die
Wirtschaft den Bach runter geht dann
geht
Unternehmen sind multinational und haben
multinationale Teams das heißt sie
brauchen also naja aber implizit haben
sie schon was dagegen weil sie eben
nicht wollen das Ausländer hierherkommen
dass ich nicht will das Ausländer
hierher kommen also mein Vater ist auch
kein Deutscher gewesen das sollte
vielleicht bekannt sein also ich bin
noch nicht dagegen dass Menschen auch
wandern und dass es auch Migration gibt
die Frage ist doch in welcher
Größenordnung in welcher Form und ob es
eben wirklich auch eine Integration
angestrebt wird und am Ende auch
erreicht wird und wir haben eine
Situation wo wir wirklich zunehmend
Gefahr laufen das Parallelgesellschaften
entstehen oder auch schon entstanden
sind das Schulen überfordert sind und
klar das betrifft alles nicht die
Menschen denen es sehr gut geht also die
in den hochpreisigen Innenstadt Bezirken
die in den Willen vierteln die können
sagen das ist eine tolle Entwicklung
haben wir noch mehr irgendwie preiswerte
haushaltskräfte und billige
Arbeitskräfte für die Menschen die in
den
wir sind weg von für immer 1995 wir sind
jetzt bei endlich 2025 Bundestagswahl
sie werden jetzt mit überwältigender
Mehrheit zur Kanzlerin gewählt und wie
machen sie jetzt Migrationspolitik das
wird mich mal interessieren wie machen
sie es konkret also jetzt ganz konkret
ganz nur ganz konkret
Lampedusa sind jetzt vor wenigen Tagen
7000 Menschen an einem einzigen Tag
angekommen in einem anderen Tag 6000 und
so weiter sind unhaltbare Zustände das
geht so nicht
wie machen sie es
wir können nicht die Armut dieser Welt
nicht durch Migration lösen sondern
deswegen müssen wir sie sind jetzt
Kanzlerin sie sitzen jetzt da sie müssen
das Thema jetzt lösen weil das haben sie
im Wahlkampf versprochen
ja dänemark hat relativ restriktiv die
Zuwanderung eingedämmt weil sie gesagt
haben wir schaffen das nicht mehr aber
was ich zusätzlich machen würde ich
finde Deutschland sollte sich dafür
einsetzen dass wir einfach gerechtere
und faire weltwirtschaftsbeziehung haben
dass die Menschen vor Ort eine
Perspektive haben ich meine wo kommen
denn die meisten Menschen her gucken Sie
mal an wo die Leute herkommen die kommen
die größten die größten
zuwanderungsgebiete also wo die Leute
hauptsächlich herkommen ist einerseits
ist Syrien warum haben die Leute in
Syrien keine Perspektive nicht zuletzt
deswegen weil es brachiale Wirtschaft
Sanktionen gegen Syrien gibt die jeden
Wiederaufbau dieses Land unmöglich jetzt
vergessen nicht zuletzt deswegen weil
ein gewisser Putin dort alles Gute zum
kleinen gebongt hat
man kann so lange das Land von allem
abgeschnitten wird solange
beispielsweise auch die USA die
lukrativen Öl vorkommen besetzt hält
also das ist ja auch völkerrechtswidrig
man kann nicht einfach so gerne gehört
Russland also russland hat komplett die
Hand da drauf nein
jegliche syrische Felder da ist die USA
also Russland ist ja nicht besetzt ja
nicht Teile dieses Land die haben ein
sehr strenges ein sehr engmaschiges
Abkommen mit Syrien für die Gebiete die
noch Syrien selber bewirtschaftet aber
eine erheblichen Teil
Bewirtschafter
ja aber das war doch auch syrisches Öl
ich meine da haben die einfach keinen
Zugriff
Wirtschaft sein und ich übersetze gerade
wäre es besser wenn dieses Land und ich
meine Würde gesagt ja es hat muss man
bekämpfen die Bevölkerung leidet unter
den Sanktion nicht Assad das sagt sie zu
fest im Sessel wie immer aber die
Menschen sind Bettel bettelarms und
haben überhaupt keine Perspektive